los partidos políticos israelíes
inscribieron sus listas definitivas para
las elecciones en el primero de
noviembre el giro inesperado fue la
ruptura de la lista conjunta árabe
provocando que sean tres y nodos en las
listas Árabes en campaña una división
que sumada a la posible baja
participación supone un riesgo para que
esta formación ese superen el umbral de
3,25% que es el necesario para acceder a
la quenesed es el último golpe para el
Primer Ministro en funciones el
centrista Yair lapid que aspira a
gobernar con el apoyo del bloque
antinetaneo el Premier tampoco logró
convencer de presentarse en Unidad a los
dos partidos de izquierda en laborista y
menetz del otro lado el ex Primer
Ministro Benjamín netaniau lidera las
encuestas con su formación licut pese a
las causas en su contra por posible
corrupción además intervino con éxito
para sumar alomofóbico noam en la
alianza de ultraderecha y también logró
la unidad de las dos formaciones Ultra
ortodoxas Aunque netaníau sale de
fortalecido de la estrategia las últimas
encuestas entregan una continuidad del
estancamiento ya que el ex Premier
estaría de 1 a 4 escaños sobre por
debajo de los 61 necesarios para formar
un gobierno desde 2019 Israel ha vivido
cuatro elecciones inconclusas y dos
gobiernos de corta duración el último
una coalición de ocho partidos se
liderada por naftalí bennett y Eloy
interino lapid interrumpió 12 años de
mandato de netaniau pero cayó víctima de
sus divisiones con poco más de un año en
el poder ahora empieza la recta final
para los comicios de noviembre que
determinarán si Israel rompe el impasse
o se enfrenta al temido escenario de una
sexta elección en cuatro años